hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american science fiction movie
called pray
the movie begins with naru a young
comanche woman waking up and preparing
herself for the day sometime in
september 1719 in the great plains she
gathers plants and herbs accompanied by
her dog sorry i she also practices
throwing axes aspiring to be a hunter
one day when noticing a deer she
attempts to hunt it down but fails as
both she and the deer are distracted by
loud rumblings of the sky which she
assumes is a thunderbird it is actually
a predator spaceship but she does not
know it yet naru then joins her older
brother tabei to hunt birds
he proudly tells her his experience of
katamiya a hunt done by a comanche tribe
member to prove himself
she thinks she is ready for her katamia
but tabe doubts it
back home naru's mother compliments her
on being an expert at everything except
hunting even though she aspires to be a
hunter
naru tells her she wants to prove
everyone else wrong that she can be a
hunter too she then notices her mother
making a mixture for the ward chief's
injured knee and asks her why she missed
an important ingredient called orange
tutsia to which her mother replies by
instructing her to collect some
after collecting the orange tutsia naru
hears a commotion saying that puhi a
tribe member was missing after
encountering a cougar
a search party is tasked with finding
him
wanting to prove herself naru brings
sorry i along and stalks the search
party although others doubt her tabe
defends her by saying she can help treat
puhi if they find puhi alive as she is
trained to know medicines and is also a
good tracker
meanwhile the predator the alien species
arrives at the comanche territory and
hunts a snake to eat in its invisible
mode
unlike other animals it brutally skins
the snake
the search party finds poohy wounded but
still breathing
naaru treats his wounds and gives him
orange tutsiya to reduce his body heat
thus minimizing the bleeding
they immediately head back home but tabe
decides to keep hunting the cougar naru
thinks it is strange for a cougar to be
far out of its den assuming there is
something far more dangerous scaring the
cougar thus worrying for tabe
however tabe ensures her that he is
going to be all right on the way home
naru finds the predator's track which is
enormous compared to other animals she
used to see in the woods
remnants of the skin snake were dumped
not far from it she questions what kind
of creature is so huge and skins a snake
like that making her worry more for tabe
and decides to go after him a young
comanche man paca accompanies her they
reach tabay waiting for the cougar
naru suggests giving the cougar bait on
the tree then they wait until the cougar
shows up to kill it
tabe is convinced that it is time for
naaru's katamia
they then get into position
paka mocks naru for not being able to
hunt underestimating her ability to kill
a cougar
then he is surprised by the cougar and
falls off the tree branch
after a quick encounter with the cougar
naru also falls off the tree but she
notices a spark beyond the trees before
she falls unconscious
naru wakes up in her home
her mother explains that tabe carried
her home and went back to finish hunting
the cougar
naru panics knowing there is something
far more dangerous out there but tabe
arrives with a severed cougar's head
the successful hunt earns him the title
of the war chief
naru confronts him uneasy because the
mysterious thing is still out there even
though he defeated the cougar
she is determined to find it even
without his permission
the next day naru goes hunting
she discovers a tree branch marked with
the glowing green blood of the predator
in its track
she practices her hunting skills and
hunts rabbits
meanwhile the predator hunts a wolf
skins it and takes its skull
naru continues her journey and discovers
a herd of dead and skinned bison
the predator hiding not far from them in
a cave hears sorry eyes bark and follows
naru's tracks across the river
sorry i goes missing while naru is
looking for it she is trapped in a
mud-filled bog pit but survives with her
axe throwing skill attaching her latched
axe to a tree trunk and pulling her body
out of the mud
she washes herself and her equipment in
the river when she spots a grizzly bear
and finds saria coming back to her the
wind changes direction causing the bear
to smell her presence
it approaches her and to add things
worse her bow string breaks just as she
is aiming for the bear
sariai distracts the bear allowing naru
to repair her bowstring she fails to hit
the bear and runs to a nearby stack of
wood the bear suddenly stops chasing
after her sensing the predator behind it
naru watches in horror as the invisible
predator easily defeats the bear and
breaks it in two
she escapes swimming downstream until
she is found by a search party led by
wasapi sent by tabe to look for her they
do not believe naru's story of the
predator thinking it is the same as the
monster and childhood stories
naru attempts to finish her hunt but
wasabi and other men tie her wrists and
then attempt to deliver her home while
the party takes a rest to drink the
predator catches up to them
it quickly decimates the whole search
party except for naru who cleverly finds
ways to escape
however her foot is stuck in a bear trap
but the predator leaves her french
trappers find her and take her hostage
she learns that they are responsible for
killing the bison their translator
raphael questions her about the predator
because she has encountered it he begs
her to help them defeat the predator
together but she refuses to talk
the trappers then reveal to her that
they have also caught top a bleeding him
to force naru to talk
they then use tabe and naru tied to a
tree as bait to the predator so they can
hunt it tabe confesses that before she
falls unconscious naru has weakened the
cougar enabling him to finish it he
admits that there are things he did not
see that naru notices
naru explains that the predator let her
live because it did not perceive her as
a threat
she is also certain that the trapper's
intention of using them as bait would
not work for the predator
her words are proven true
the predator uses its fighting skills
and advanced weapons to decimate the
frenchman while naru and tabe free
themselves
naru is unsure whether the predator can
be killed but tabe convinces her that if
it bleeds it can be killed they part
ways naaru back to the french camp to
free saria and reclaim her weapons while
tabe gets one of the escaped frenchman's
horses
at the french camp naru defeats the
remaining trappers and frees sariai when
she notices raphael missing one of his
limbs begging her to treat his wounds in
exchange for information on how to use
his pistol
naru gives him the orange tootsie as she
keeps in her pockets causing him to
shiver
she then senses the predator nearby and
runs to hide while raphael plays dead
naru is shocked when she observes the
predator not immediately attacking
raphael as if he is invisible to it only
after it steps on raphael's leg and he
screams that it notices him and kills
him she deduces that consuming the
orange tutsia or lowering body
temperature will make a person invisible
to the predator
sorry i comes barking and just before
the predator is about to attack it tabe
arrives on horseback impaling the
predator at one point the predator's
mask falls off troubling its projectile
aim after an intense battle tabe
realizes they are losing against it and
allows naru to escape while he is
impaled from the back by the predator
one of the tribe members delivers tabe's
weapons to his mother informing her that
he is dead
naru loads raphael's gun by the river
and notices a surviving french man
washing nearby
instead of shooting him she knocks him
unconscious severs one of his legs and
baits him to use an unloaded gun while
the french man curses at her and is
preparing to shoot her she bites the
orange tootsie as she senses the
predator nearby
her plan works as the predator walks
past her and directly attacks the french
man
she knocks on the predator's mask and
takes it then flees
naru ambushes the predator by lurching
herself towards it from the top of a
tree
she does not try to kill it as she knows
its strength is much greater than her
instead she traps him inside a
mud-filled bog pit where she was trapped
earlier then positions herself in front
of tree branches to make the predator
aim its projectiles at her
unbeknownst to it she already placed its
mask in a position that will cause the
projectile to blow past its head
effectively killing it
she screams at her victory and takes the
predator's head and raphael's pistol
back to her tribe
naru is welcomed by her tribe with cheer
and joy
she informs the chief that they need to
move to safer ground as there are
threats nearby
as tabe is deceased she has made the new
warchief in the end credits three
predator spaceships arrive at the
comanche grounds
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching